one more movie that you just had come
out recently that I was curious about
was Capone of course working with Josh
Trank and I hope i phrase this correctly
but from the reporter perspective on the
outside
we're busy covering Fantastic Four like
crazy and hearing about everything and
things are going wrong and we're all
like oh no now josh is never gonna make
another movie again then he makes Capone
his way exactly how he wants to so is
that just a result of our limited
perspective of what's going on or when
you consider taking a role like that
does any of that information come your
way and do you have to parse through it
I own I didn't parse through that at all
I really didn't I met Josh you know I
had I had received I had received some
interests and letters and and you know
and I just was asked to join and I and I
met Josh and I it seemed Chronicle which
I thought was fantastic you know and I
met Josh and I I love them
I think he's so interesting he's so
smart he is very generous Tom loves him
I love Tom's work I there's you know I
mean nobody better I just it's there's
never any consideration about any of
that stuff to me because being on this
side you know that there are stories
told about people and there are multiple
sizes of those stories and who knows
what's what so I just I don't really
ever go into anything
based on what I've heard and I as a
result I tend to have wonderful
experiences with people that people ask
me you know oh so-and-so had a bad
experience and then I'll be it I will be
completely shocked because I am sort of
out of it I don't really pay that much
attention to a lot of that stuff at
times I mean it absent flows but also I
just you never know you never know what
somebody's going through in any period
of time whether you hear a story about
an actor who or actress who misbehaves
or a producer or a director whoever it
I think you know it's a long life in
this business if you're lucky and you
will go through things and you have to
hope that that that's part of it too
it's like life you know so none of that
mattered to me I met him I loved him
I loved the script I loved the idea of
doing something that was so out of that
field that people thought they were
going to see this you know shoot him up
you know Kapow a movie and it's the
opposite of what you're expecting
I liked the sort of left turn of that
and everybody involved I had such a good
time on that movie you know and Josh is
at the top of bringing everybody in we
had the best time making that movie we
were all in this mansion in Florida
making this movie and it was it was it
was a real exercise and imagination and
fun and challenging and we it was a
party we had a great time so none of
that stuff matters what matters to me is
day to day and if I feel like I can be
treated with love and respect and if I
can treat the work with love and respect
them that's what I do